>> So, we've answered the thing about continuous attributes.
Now, here's another thing. When do we really stop?
>> When we get all the answers right. When
all the training examples are in the right category. Class.
>> Right, so the the answer in
the algorithm is when everything is classified correctly.
That's a pretty good answer, Michael. But what if we have
noise in our data? What if it's the case that we
have two examples of the same object, the same instance, but
they have two different labels? Then this will never be the case.
>> Oh. So, then our algorithm goes into an infinite loop.
>> Which seems like a bad idea.
>> So we could have, we could, we could
just say, or we've run out of attributes. [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] Or we've run out
of attributes. That's one way of doing
it. In fact, that, that was, that's going to
have to happen at some point, right?
That's probably a slightly better answer. Although that
doesn't help us in the case where we have continuous attributes and we might ask
an infinite number of questions. So we probably
need a slightly better criteria. Don't you think?
>> Hm.
>> So, what got us down this path, was thinking about what happens
if we have noise. Why would we be worried about having noise anyway?
>> Noise anyway.
Well, I guess the training data might have gotten corrupted
a little bit or maybe somebody copied something down wrong.
>> Right, so since that's always a possibility,
does it really make sense to trust the
data completely, and go all the way to
the point where we perfectly classify the training data?
>> But Charles, if we can't trust our data, what can we trust?
>> Well, we can trust our data, but we want to verify. [LAUGH]
The whole point is generalization. And if it's possible for us to have
a little bit of noise in the data, an error here or there,
then we want to have some way to deal to handle that possibility, right?
>> I guess so.
>> So, what will we do?
>> [LAUGH] I mean, we actually have a name for this, right? When you get
really, really, really good at classifying your training
data, but it doesn't help you to generalize,
we have a name for that.
>> Right. That sounds like overfitting.
>> Exactly. We have to worry about overfitting.
So you can overfit with the decision tree too?
>> Yeah. What, you don't believe that?
>> No, no, no. I was, I was being naive, I was being,
I know that you can overfit a decision tree. [LAUGH] I was just.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah but your [SOUND] is the [SOUND] that
you use when you're, when you're like, I don't believe what
you just said Charles, but I'm going to go along with
it anyway, because I have to get off the phone soon.
>> [LAUGH] Fair enough. I'll try to,
I'll try to have a different personality then.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, step one, have a
different personality with maximal information gain. Okay, so
we don't want to, we don't want to overfit. So we need to come up with some
way of overfitting. Now the way you overfit in a decision tree is basically by
having a tree that's too big, it's
too complicated. All right. Violates Occam's Razor. So,
what's a kind of, let's say, modification to something like ID3
to our decision tree algorithm that will help us to avoid overfitting?
>> Well last time we talked about overfitting,
we said cross-validation was a good way of dealing
with it, which, it allowed us to choose
from among the different, say degrees of the polynomial.
>> Right.
>> So maybe we could do something like that?
I don't know. Try all the different trees and,
see which one has the lowest cross
validation error? Maybe there's too many trees.
>> Maybe, but that's a perfectly reasonable thing to do,
right? You take out a validation set. You build a
decision tree, and you test it on the, on the
validation set and you pick whichever one has the lowest error
in the validation sect, that's one way to avoid it.
And then you have, don't have to worry about this question
about stopping, you just grow the tree on the training
set minus the validation set until it does well on that.
And you check it against the crossvalid, you check it against
the validation set, and you pick the best one. That's one way
of doing it, and that would work perfectly fine. There is
another way you can do it that's more efficient. Which is, you
do the same idea validation, except that you hold out a
set and as you, everytime you decide whether to expand the tree
or not, you check to see how this would do so
far in the validation set. And if the error is low enough,
then you stop expanding the tree. That's one way of doing it.
>> So is there, is there a problem in terms of, I mean if
we're expanding the tree depth for search wise, we could be at, you know,
we could be looking at one tiny little split on one side of the
tree before we even look at any, anything on the other side of the tree.
>> That's a fine point. So how would you fix that?
>> Maybe expand breadth first?
>> Yeah, that would probably do it. Anything else you could think of? Well,
so, you could do pruning, right? You could go ahead and
do the tree as if you didn't have to worry about
over-fitting, and once you have the full tree built, you could
then do a kind of, you could do pruning. You could
go to the leaves of the tree and say, well, what
if I collapse these leaves back up into the tree? How
does that create error on my validation set? And if the
error is too big, then you don't do it. And if it's
very small, then you go ahead and do
it. And that should help you with overfitting.
So, that whole class of ways of doing
it, is called pruning. And there's a whole bunch
of different ways you might prune. But pruning,
itself, is one way of dealing with overfitting,
and giving you a smaller tree. And it's
a very simple addition to the standard ID3 algorithm.